meanwhile a new york times investigation
has revealed the u.s may have mistakenly
targeted an aid worker in a drone strike
that killed 10 people in afghanistan's
capital in august charlotte bellis has
more from kabul
in that drone strike the pentagon said
that it hit isil bombers who were
planning an imminent attack on the
airport we know that civilians were
killed in that but now this
investigation has used cctv footage has
talked to more than a dozen of the
targets family members and colleagues
and found out that he was actually
a worker for a u.s aid organization they
also showed that he was loading
canisters of of water into the car and
not explosion explosives as the pentagon
had said
and they are also alleging that there
wasn't secondary explosions which is
what the pentagon used to prove that
they knew that there were explosives in
the car so the pentagon has responded
saying that we are assessing results of
the airstrike we work hard to prevent
civilian casualties and it was based on
good intelligence but
for for afghans here's a lot of
criticism and and they also find it
quite symbolic that the last air strike
that happened in in this nearly 20-year
war killed civilians and others big
question marks over whether they had the
right person